let's bring in the Hall of Famer Reggie
Miller boy Reggie has a great Sunday
every Sunday Reggie gets to sit down and
watch Michael Jordan the Chicago Bulls
this is the worst assignment you've had
probably since you were in school at
UCLA reg oh my good I would take UCLA
right now this education I'm going
through every Sunday but I will say you
know watching I think it was the end of
episode 7 last night MJ you don't need
to apologize
you only do apologize of what your DNA
is because this is what I tell people at
the end of the day the headlines it's
not going to be built winning team let
us down
BJ Armstrong let us down Jud Buechler
let us down Steve Kerr not even Scottie
Pippen the headline is going to be
Michael Jordan so you have to be a
taskmaster you have to whip guys in the
shape don't apologize for that that's
your DNA that is how I was somewhat
raised because I was raised by magic
environs God Michael Cooper win at all
costs
absolutely and if you don't want to fall
in line you see the door bull I I don't
want to hear it and you know when Steve
it's funny because when Steve Kerr and
is kind of reminiscing on the fight
that's every Tuesday
that's where every Wednesday during the
90s during practices you always fought
your teammates I think it in today's age
of social media it would have been blown
up but it's that well I'm looking at
them like yeah so oh okay I got to fight
you know many times I got in a fight
with Dale Davis Antonio Davis I mean so
that happened did you ever throw a punch
of course that's what fights are we you
think fight their words yes a lot of
some pushing and shoving
I saw problems with words Reggie
well we didn't solve problems with words
afterwards afterwards we would talk it
out but sometimes you got to have a
little tough love
so why'd I you know when he was you know
it got emotional about it you know
before this dot came out he was talking
about you know people are gonna think
you know they're gonna see me in a
different light and they're gonna think
I'm a bad person yeah that's what made
him great I was surprised that he cared
this much about being liked because I
don't think Michael when he played cared
about being liked he wanted to be feared
and he wanted to be respected
maybe he's mellowing a little bit here
where I don't think so to me if you're
asking me personally this is what I
personally feel I think that's an act I
think he could he could care less what
people think really wait you think that
crying last night was an act no that was
real okay
that was real but I I don't think he
cares what what people think that's what
made him MJ that's what made him the
black cat black black Jesus that's what
made him but when he goes to the Hall of
Fame and he makes it a roast these are
all accomplished people like Mike never
turned it off and and you can imagine
hey I'm gonna make fun of Scottie
Burrell and judge Buller and Bill
winning t'l Hall of Famers to their
faces here that's why I'm saying he he
couldn't care less what people think
about him because he can't turn it off
yeah because it's his DNA and that's
what made him great when he says because
you've never want anything except that's
what it is it it takes a level you got
to go to different and dark places and
he has and Allen T he should apologize
for that because he is the goat he's the
greatest player of my generation of any
generation and he shouldn't have to
apologize for how he is wired because he
brought a lot of joy
a to the city of Chicago and a lot of
money and a lot of people's pockets his
teammates the league so he shouldn't
have to apologize for that are there
things that I'm sure he wishes he could
have said or done differently I'm sure
that's not his DNA but why can't he give
credit where credit is due he doesn't if
there's one thing I do there's ways like
him laughing at Gary Payton that was
wrong and to me that is wrong because
there's ways he could have said yeah you
know what he made me work in those two
games but you know I came back and gave
it to them the rest there's ways he
could have framed it but guess what guys
that's why he has six six finals six
finals MVP and the goat right that's why
he threw shade at Clyde he threw shade
at Dan Majerle he's throwing shade at
Isiah on next next week so I mean this
is what made him wait do you know and
you read it to anyone do you know what's
gonna happen next weekend I have no idea
what is going to happen if I knew did
you want to know what I've been watching
and he had killed everyone Craig Ehlo
Dan Majerle
he threw shade at Clyde he had not been
equal he just laughed in Gary Payton
Gary was different to Player of the Year
Hall of Famer you're right it doesn't
matter I think the only people he he
probably hasn't thrown shade maybe magic
hilarious you know those guys are what
helped pave the way for him but us
little minions that you came after him
no I there's part of me that hopes he
goes after you oh he's going but that's
because you you know you got to it Mike
he only go he's going after you if you
know there was really something that was
going on that's why I want people to
understand him laughing and people like
wanting to like throw shade at Gary
Payton he's laughing because he knew
Gary brought it and Gary wasn't backing
down
Jerry's one of those dudes you can walk
through an alley with alright yeah so
he's laughing out that but in jammu come
on man he knew so again I don't know nor
do I care but as long as he at the end
of day he respected me and maybe he
doesn't respect me I don't care
I really don't but it was fun
are you sure I will that he respected me
or didn't really know that you don't
care I don't care really
I don't ever you I don't care BMG likes
me or not
well no respect is one thing like
whatever so if he does every desert is
that going to change my life
no okay it's not going to change my life
do you say anything negative about him
[Laughter]
Paulie would you would you text the
director I'm on adjacent hair and asked
if Reggie said anything mean about
Michael you never know he could have I
could have said hey you're a little late
on that screen and he could have been
like you know he's the worst if it's a
player a long time he could have thought
that right so who knows in his mind what
he's thinking I mean the hold of
Bradford because I do remember that any
little flight you know he was gonna use
so oh well did you say anything after a
game to dirt did you say like good game
oh you did I was thought yes but I was
very young when I was a rookie you know
and he let me know you know that's why
the whole black Jesus thing came up he's
like don't ever speak to black Jesus
like that
okay wait first of all you refer to
yourself in the third party for calling
yourself like Jesus I said that to
myself
so set the scene where Mike refers to
himself in third person I'm a rookie
exhibition game we're playing on one of
these crazy small towns because that's
where exhibition games are the kind of
the wealth and the love of basketball
and Mike's going through the motion
you know it's an exhibition game who
cares I'm a rookie I'm going 130 miles
an hour because I'm trying to show my
teammates and you're going against
Michael Jordan and Chuck person's egging
me on like that's Michael Jordan really
look what you're doing to him no he's
just Michael just going through it right
you know I got 10 or 12 by half he has
like two or four and I'm like just
talking to like you can walk on water
that's what they say this is it this is
Air Jordan and it looks at me it's like
okay so the second half ends with 45 so
I end with I had 10 I ended with 12 so
he outscored me 42 and as we're walking
off he suddenly says hey don't ever talk
to black Jesus like and I looked at
Chuck and Chuck like shrugged your
shoulder I was like you're right black
Jesus and I just kept walking off and
that kind of would probably started our
somewhat contentious relationship but I
should have known better you know but I
couldn't hold I can't hold my tongue
that's my problem but you think that he
respected the fact that you went at him
[Laughter]
I can't wait I just hope that my gun
loads on you he will I do but that was
my thinking like what people are saying
yeah we we all know how that turned out
you trying to retire Michael Jordan is
that wrong for me employment that should
be my thinking yes I would I can't speak
for the rest of my teammates but that
was my thinking like this is my this is
my chance I've got a team I got my guy
you have your guys you're the champs
you're Michael Jordan I do want to
retire you it didn't happen but that
should be my thinking you guys should
have won you you can hop it you're gonna
make it hurt that was a you guys had a
great
you had a better all-around team than
the Bulls did it hurts it really does
hurt and more so game 7 2 in their place
because it was all set up I mean we're
up 6 see this is how well you know it
because you read people always say God
made so many great moments it's not the
great moments I really love it's the
hurtful ones that are on rewind in my
brain we're up six that jump ball
between Scottie Pippen and seven for Rik
Smits and it's on their side if we win
that jump ball because it's on their
side of the court we wouldn't that jump
ball go down a score we go up eight with
like under floor to go
you could start massaging the game by
then mm-hmm
they win the tip Scottie wants to tip
the ball finds his way to Steve Kerr he
knocks down a three and from six to
three and it was like a snowball effect
after that we we just couldn't hold on
and I just relived that moment over and
over if we could have won that jump ball
and score to just put more pressure I'm
not to say we would have ended up
winning but it may it makes it a little
bit more difficult so yeah it's it's the
hurtful moments you remember more are
you sure you're going to be emotionally
ready to talk about this next Monday yes
I'm it's good to talk it out especially
with family like yourself and my Danette
it's good it'll be good wait what's your
what's your wife think about I'm glad
people get a sense of how competitive
things were in the 90s and the eighties
really late 80s but to have a camera and
see him see him going off and it if you
will get understand that's nothing that
is absolutely nothing what he was how he
is reeling off on his teammates that's
nothing guys that is that's easy trash
talk is you can understand what goes on
between games oh my god people that is
nothing what you're seeing do you need
an emotional support dog I need
something I really do a
it's good because you know I'm sitting
I'm watching this with mama bear and I
tell her go stood on the other side of
the couch because my palms sweaty
because and then when the commercials
come and she's looking at me and you
know I got like sweat coming down she's
like are you okay I'm like no I'm not
okay because it brings back it it brings
back those memories good and bad and I'm
excited about next week because I know
he's going to kill me but I'm gonna take
it as a badge because he's gone after
everyone else in this docu-series so you
might as well come after us you should
wear your whole uniform next Sunday I
want to take some pictures yes yes get
your sweaty hands on and yeah hopefully
I am going to watch this in full garb
yes no that's good hey before I let you
go Shaq says that we shouldn't have a
season because nobody's gonna recognize
this year's champion is a true champion
what do you make I think they will
definitely recognize it but I do agree I
think we're getting to that point where
we may need to just scrap this and and
start anew next year I just don't see
any positive things coming out of
restarting this we're two months in now
right yeah I think we'll get a lot of
injuries once we come back because guys
are going to try to then they won't
train right and you see a lot of these
injuries at the start of the season
because guys are not in shape I just
don't see any benefit from it so I think
if there we do resume play and there is
a champion
there won't be an asterisk behind it
because it's still the championship just
like the lockout year when San Antonio
Juan and Phil Jackson was saying there's
going to be a strict no you ended up
winning the championship you'll be
recognized as that but I do agree with
him we should start really looking
next season and just starting fresh well
you know leave it to LeBron to win this
year so then people have more of an
argument that it doesn't really count as
a championship you know with this whole
Jordan phenomenon going on it would just
it would be so LeBron liked to win and
then have people hold it against him
and not only that let's say they do
scrap the season and we start again next
year in October November December or
whatever they think about starting again
LeBron's and a year older now - that's
the only thing and he didn't he was
having in MVP he wasn't going to win the
MVP
to me that was Yanis but he was 1a and
1b he was going to be second in the MVP
voting all right just get ready like
gear up Sunday night like it you're
gearing up for a game what music did you
listen to in the locker room before
games Tupac ooh
huge Tupac fans oh yes all eyes on me so
I'll probably be having that plane as
I'm in full pacer gear and it's ready to
go all eyes on me
mm-hmm guard out of UCLA six foots are
you six seven or six six six seven sixty
giving my inch
I can't wait Thank You reg I'll talk to
you next Monday y'all this is gonna be
so good